in this short video I would like to show
you how to use the demo pipelines on the
platform and specifically focus on the
amplicon 16 s 18 s pipeline using data
to
when you open the platform you will see
something like this so you have to click
on this drop down once you click on the
drop down you will be inside the demo
section of the pipeline by using this
pipeline you will understand the inputs
and the outputs and some explanation
about every step much more detail about
how the pipeline's work and what is the
type of data that they analyse can be
found on the educational site
edu dot t-- - bio dot info you can see
it right here so let's go back and we'll
start this pipeline you first click on
the start button and here you can see
the input files for the input files we
will use an SVM which is a server
reference file that will show where the
path to the file is on our high
performance cluster you will also see
this txt table now if you open this
table you will be able to see that the
table contains some information about
the samples in this case we are going to
use six different samples and some have
Chow which is a regular diet and high
fat diet
these are mouse microbiome fecal samples
F here stands for fecal now also there's
some explanation here about the context
how is the data generated the
hypervariable regions and also the
taxonomy of the different microbial
communities that are going to be found
in some of these samples once we start
we can now use the data to section that
is going to perform several steps to
prepare the reads clean them up
normalize them and then combine them
into ot use organizational taxonomic
units that will later on we'll reveal
the taxonomy of this microbial
communities that we are studying so
let's take a look first
we are going to filter based on quality
and here's some introduction into the
full data to bioinformatics workflow and
you can see that they are going to be
good quality and low quality reads and
we're going to also compare how those
reads are comparable between each sample
now we can click on ok we're going to
make sure that we only take a good good
pairs of reads and use only those to
identify Oh to use merge those pairs
together prepare consensus clusters
remove climbers so those reads that
contain those o to use that contain
combinations that are not really
relevant and then assign the taxonomy
now how do we know that taxonomy the
economy actually is based on these hyper
variable regions is stored in a database
so we can look for the those and
identify the taxonomic breakdown of
communities we see in the samples now
then we're going to use another package
called Philo seek that will help us
build some visualization plots APE Philo
seek and end and now after we do end we
will have several outputs and this demo
pipeline just demonstrates what type of
outputs will you actually get so you can
see here that we can look at the
abundance of different types of
microbial communities that we have in
our sample we can look at outputs
graphical outputs like plots from Philo
seek and we can also get sequences of
owed to use let's take a look at the
Philo see plots Philo seek plots are
divided into two main sections the alpha
diversity and the beta diversity that
you can see down towards the bottom in
the alpha diversity we can take a look
at logarithmic scale of abundance
and compare that abundance between
samples by family an option that you can
select when you are building the
pipeline when you are not using the demo
pipeline you can also look at the
relationships between ot use in terms of
their taxonomy and abundance calculate
the alpha diversity measure using two
different options
tchau and Shannon and also look at beta
diversity where we can see the
difference whether there is a
significant difference between the two
groups that we are trying to analyze
high fat diet and Chow samples to
summarize the demo pipeline is a good
way to understand how a pipeline works
what type of inputs and outputs you
would get from a pipeline and get ready
to consider how this analysis might be
useful for your data